so so before I get started I'm just
curious how many of you have ever heard
of the term Thunder lizard before okay
so a few so why don't I get started just
level setting on that for a little bit
so um yeah so Thunder lizards so the
metaphor actually comes from Godzilla so
I'm interested in not just companies
that are doing a startup but companies
that are doing something hyper
exceptional and I was seeking a metaphor
to describe these companies and I wanted
it to combine the ideas of being big
adaptable fearsome radioactive and so
and it just didn't seem right to use a
term like disruptive innovation or
something to to academically sounding
and so even though we are in an esteemed
academic institution right now so came
up with this term Thunder lizard about
20 years ago
and Thunder lizards for those of you who
are not familiar with Godzilla were
hatched from radioactive atomic eggs and
this is actually the stage of the market
that we at floodgate like to invest in
and so we like to say that our job is to
spot radioactive atomic eggs you know
when we invested in Twitter they weren't
sure whether they were gonna call it
twtr or TW TTR or voicemail 2.0 and you
know when when when we invested in lift
before it launched you know we had to
get comfortable with the legal ambiguity
of that service and so so you know at
the time that we see this stuff it's
hard to even know what its gonna mutate
into but but but the goal is to find
companies that have sort of
radioactivity at their roots and then
they swim across the ocean and emerge
with an attitude and then and then they
begin to devour their startup
competitors right as they hit the beach
and then not long after that they begin
to disrupt even more swiping holes into
the sides of building
and then eventually they attack the
incumbents the incumbents in the market
are represented by those trains that
he's eating like sausage links so that
is uh so now you know what
thunderlizards are and you know I like
to use that term because we've been
we've been lucky to have worked with
some people who have arguably created
these kinds of companies so we have it
we haven't been at this for very long we
got started a little over ten years ago
but so far the cumulative exit value the
companies we've invested in is more than
thirty billion and so some of those
companies have ended up sort of you know
breaking out in an exponential way and
so I thought I thought it would be
helpful like a lot of you probably get a
cross-section of speakers here what I
thought I would really focus on is what
can we learn from the people who build
these truly exceptional companies not
just the top 1% of companies but the 0.1
percent or the 0.01% of the very best
startups so I have two main thoughts the
first thought is the exponential laws of
entrepreneurship and so the exponential
there's three exponential laws I'm going
to talk about and I think they basically
animate startup opportunity I think that
they are fundamentally the three
asymmetric weapons of the startup the
first is one that probably most of you
so how many of you have heard of Moore's
law okay
everybody pretty much right so Moore's
law says that the performance of
computing doubles every 18 months at a
given price now it's funny we take
Moore's law for granted but Moore's law
is very profound Moore's law guarantees
that the tech industry will remain
magical and the reason that Moore's law
is so powerful is because the power
compound interest it give me an
incumbent of any arbitrary size give
Moore's law enough time and it will read
it will breach the advantage of any
incumbent
company no matter how powerful that
company's position is in the market and
so the thing that is so important for
our industry about Moore's law is it
guarantees a continuous supply of new
awesome companies that change the way we
view the world and that could be
potentially disruptive how many people
have heard of Metcalfe's law just a show
of hands okay so not nearly as many
people so Metcalfe's law is named after
Bob Metcalfe Metcalfe Bob Metcalfe is
widely regarded as one of the prime
movers of inventing the Ethernet and so
Metcalfe's law is about network effects
so Metcalfe's law basically states that
the value of the network is a function
of the square of the number of the nodes
and if you think about it it makes sense
every new node that gets added to a
network has the potential to connect to
all the prior nodes of the network it so
as the as the network gets larger it has
more nodes you know some people argue
that it's not a hundred percent
exponential but it approaches
exponential increasing returns okay how
many of you have heard of the power law
okay not that many as well this might
surprise you so there are more than
10,000 startups in a typical year
created and actually right now we're in
a little bit more of a frothy time so
it's more like twenty to thirty thousand
ten of those companies create 97% of all
the exit value in the industry that's
really hard for people get their mind
around you know like most that this by
the way this is why venture capital and
startups are not an asset class most
asset classes follow things like the
capital asset pricing model or they
follow things like a normal distribution
of returns where you have a one sigma
event this way for the better and once
they've event this way for the worse
that's not how power laws work they work
like this right so my first first angel
fund I had that had Twitter in it we
made more than 500 times
on our investment it didn't matter that
two other companies in that group of
investments went public Twitter
dominated all the returns in our in our
in the next fund we had demand force
returned three times the fund by itself
lift has that kind of power and the fund
after that and so here are some other
statistics so for example what we find
is in a typical startup year the best
startup of the year is generally more
valuable than all other startups created
that year combined so Facebook was
created in 2004 more valuable than all
other tens of thousands of startups
combined created in 2004 Paul Graham
once told me at Y Combinator in that I
think that the values have flipped now
because this is about three four years
ago he told me at the time the Dropbox
was worth more than all 550 other
companies that they had run through
their accelerator at the time and that
Airbnb was worth more than all the
remaining combined and so on so what the
power law basically states is that
generally speaking the value of the best
outcome will exceed the combined value
of all the remaining outcomes and then
the value the second-best outcome will
exceed the value of all remaining
outcomes and so on okay so I said that
the first key thought was about
exponential reasoning this is tech
entrepreneurship in one slide it is
leveraging the power of Moore's Law and
or Metcalfe's law to create an
extraordinary outcome that's the whole
business well everybody I know well for
the most part who's really done well in
Silicon Valley was involved in one of
those extraordinary companies either as
a founder as an employee maybe even as a
lawyer right but it's like if you're if
you're not trying to be one of the top
ten companies of the year you're
competing with 9990 other companies for
three percent of the scraps in the
industry
so the first thing that I like to
emphasize to people when they start a
company is start a company that's worthy
of your talents that you think
represents the absolute utmost gift you
have to offer to this world in your life
because to be one of those that's what
it takes
people shouldn't just be doing a
start-up well I should back up if you
decide to just be doing a startup that's
fine but that's that's kind of like the
decision to join a non-profit or it's
kind of like a decision to you know it's
kind of a labor of love it may make the
world better but don't do it because you
think you're gonna make money
approaching it that way because that's
not what the objective function of the
industry is so then about now people
often ask me okay great there's three
exponential laws there's Moore's law
there's Metcalfe's law I want to combine
them in some way to create a huge
outcome but like how do I have you know
how do I harness the potential energy of
those three laws into the mechanical
energy of an awesome startup that
actually does the disrupting and and you
know achieves its Thunder lizard
ambitions so that's what I wanted to
work on and this is a thought that it's
a framework that we like to use it at
floodgate that sort of captures a lot of
what we've seen is patterns and some of
the really good companies and so we call
it the value stack the value stack is
really you could think of it as a
hierarchy of powers and so as you go up
the stack the force multiplication of
each power builds upon the power of
beneath it and amplifies it even further
and so the first one we'll talk about
soon is proprietary power the purpose of
proprietary powers have an unfair
advantage the best way to compete is to
choose not to and proprietary power
allows us to avoid the trap of
competition a product power is the thing
that everybody talks about in Silicon
Valley
right now it's build something people
want product market fit awesome user
experience all that kind of stuff but
there's some subtlety there too company
power has to do so but before I jump
into this topic raise your hand if
you've ever heard the term technical
debt or management debt okay so
technical debt is sort of like when you
make short-term expedient decisions of
the technology that sort of cost you
later right you may be in order to ship
something on time you had to cut some
corners and the architecture wasn't as
elegant as it could have been or the you
know that the just the attention to
detail or bug fixing maybe wasn't as
good as it could have been and so when I
was a kid there was this there was this
commercial fram oil filters and the guy
would say you can pay me now or you
could pay me later and it's so technical
debt is sort of like when you when you
when you put off some things that you
have to solve later but then they cost
you more money in time after the fact
and management debt is the same thing
but it's for lack of having management
systems in place and you know if you
have too much management debt if the
company starts to take off and do really
well you don't have the eternal capacity
and wherewithal to scale to the speed of
that opportunity might scale and then
the last thing is category power this is
something that I think you know just
like in the last ten years
like I remember getting to know Steve
Blank really well about ten years ago
and he was working on this book called
the four steps to the Epiphany and it
kind of ushered in this era of customer
development then Eric Ries was talking
about lean startups
I think category design over the next
couple of years will be one of the next
frontiers that people start to talk
about in Silicon Valley sort of at the
same level that now they're talking
about that had been talk about lean
startups and customer development so
we're going to talk a little bit about
that as well ok let's start with
proprietary power avoiding the need to
compete so when I was in business school
if you'd ask the typical MBA student at
the time
what is capitalism they would have said
something like
it is a system characterized by multiple
firms competing for the preference of
empowered customers in a free market or
something like that and I guess I would
assert that that's actually not true
that true capitalism and capitalists are
opposites I like to say that a
capitalist is a person who aggregates
capital based on an unfair advantage and
so those are the best capitalists I know
and so why is that important well what I
find is that too many people in Silicon
Valley too many entrepreneurs too many
companies engage in what I like to call
mindless competition and you've probably
seen pitches like this before where one
of the slides of the deck has the
company presenting and then five other
companies and we check all the boxes and
the other companies check a fraction of
the boxes and when I see that slide I
almost always pass on the investment and
the reason is it bugs me when somebody
doesn't realize that being different is
more important than being better and it
doesn't it and that the best competitive
strategy is to choose not to compete we
talked about this already sometimes I
get in trouble for using the word
monopoly that word offends people
sometimes in other places but so like
let me just use a more benign word or
term do you have a structural
competitive advantage and so first mover
advantage when you think about it isn't
a very durable advantage there's a lot
of smart people in this world but if you
have a structural competitive advantage
what that means is that even at scale
your competitors can't attack you
effectively so you know you think about
it for example being spent has now spent
over ten billion dollars in search
trying to dislodge Google has gotten
nowhere trying and so and that's because
Google has a structural competitive
advantage we won't use the term
monopolies to describe Google's search
position
okay sources of proprietary power this
is the one that I think usually applies
most to people like it's a Stanford it's
deep technology and I like to say that
really harnessing a technology advantage
is a proxy for leveraging Moore's law
and so whenever I look at a company that
says they have a technology advantage
I'm interested in a couple things one is
just what is the advantage and why would
it be hard to copy but then the other
part of the question is why now you know
why why did something in the world
change to open the world for this
opportunity you know what if you're
doing topological data analysis why
couldn't that have been done five years
ago why couldn't that have been done ten
years ago well it turned out that
computational capacity in the cloud was
improving improving improving at the
rate of Moore's Law and eventually
converged at a critical point where it
became practical so there are two
companies the reason I like using these
examples apart from the fact that I just
like the companies and the founders is
they both came out of Stanford and they
both have technology depth in their
advantage so the first one is a Yazdi
how many of you have heard of the Yazdi
just out of curiosity so quite a few so
well a few more than I thought though
so what a yosity has is a I'm gonna
butcher the an we'll probably not like
the the lack of precision that I use to
describe it but there's this there's
this capability called topological data
analysis and there were a bunch of PhDs
and smart students at Stanford who had
been inventing this new way of analyzing
data and what what topological data
analysis does is it lets you run data
through a system and rather than start
with a query I'm looking for this it
lets you find unexpected relationships
in the data and it turns out that a lot
of data has emergent properties a lot of
data is very complex it's unstructured
and sometimes the fact that you think
you know the question means you have a
bias about what you're looking for
sometimes you just want to say run the
data through this thing
show me a fractal and then I could see
patterns I didn't even know I was
looking for so it's more of a discovery
oriented way of finding patterns rather
than a query based way of finding
patterns so when we funded a Yazdi you
say to yourself okay is anybody gonna
pay for that we had no idea right when
Ann went in chased down Gurjeet and
tried to write him a check outside of
his classroom
I think all it was a set of math papers
like I you know there was no business
plan there was like I didn't even
understand it to be honest it was a
bunch of calculus topological data
equations and I was like okay well
that's great but I thought we were
talking about a Yazdi and this business
plan and like there was there's none of
that so anyhow so in a company like that
you have high market risk right you
don't know if you're gonna ever find a
buyer for this technology you don't know
if you can even make a product that
people will buy but do you have a lot of
risk that somebody's gonna copy the
technology not so much right because
like the vast majority of all of the
people in the world who had invented
this TDA approach were early employees
of a Yazdi it's so like if the world
decides oh boy I need me some of that
topological data analysis chances are a
las diez got an unfair advantage you
know in delivering that second company
in scope --ax so not all of you might be
able to read this fluorescence
microscopes there they're normally this
big they're like the size of that you
fit them on a table they cost like a
quarter of a million bucks you can't
move them very easily unfortunately in
order to have this even be semi legible
people probably don't realize this thing
is smaller than a shot glass it's like
half the size of a shot glass so you can
put plug it into the USB port of a side
of a computer you could put one of these
things on the top of a mouse like
literally as its scurrying around and
study how different neurons in the brain
fire so what happens when it discovers
cheese what happens is it learns
a certain path in the maze what happens
if it sees cheese five times in a row
and then the next time it doesn't you
begin to be able to explore the brain in
new ways that you never could have
before and because these things are so
small you can put them in a raise you
can take them to developing parts of the
world that can't afford these $250,000
big microscopes that are hard to move in
the first place and so you know if you
could build a full stack of software on
top of these microscopes then you might
have something
but like yet again right this isn't you
know like a one of the companies I
invested in a long time ago that had
Network effects was dig and Kevin Rose
started dig for fifteen hundred dollars
over a weekend and you're not just gonna
have somebody in a garage start this for
fifteen hundred dollars over a weekend
right this is somebody with heavy-duty
PhD chops you know understanding stuff
that nobody else understands the reason
I bring this up is that a lot of times
when I talk to students you know
sometimes I'm an advisor at some of
these classes and I've noticed that a
lot of times the the startup idea they
want to do in the class is like okay
we're like a social network but for
mobile phones and people at college do
an XYZ and I'm like Cawood what what
what a tragic waste of the opportunity
because I think that a lot of you will
appreciate some day maybe more than now
that a lot of the stuff that you're
working on is very cutting edge like
when I was when I was at Stanford I was
just like okay you know there's this new
thing coming out called jaw C++ and you
know it kind of seems like it might be a
thing here pretty soon and nobody's
really using it yet and none of my
friends back home know anything about it
but I get yeah I guess I better learn
C++ why not and so like there's just
things that happen where you're like
literally on the cutting edge of
something and you're in the right place
at the right time to have a technical
breakthrough insight that the rest of
the world doesn't widely understand yet
it's it's like it's like I'm an old guy
right I'm like in my 40s
and I've lived my entire life in
Cartesian coordinates right now one of
you may be you may discover hey the
world also runs in polar coordinates and
if that's all you've seen right if
you're a 20 year old and the only way
you've ever viewed the world is through
polar coordinates you don't have to do
any translation right you I mean you
just know what to do whereas old guy
like me I'm like okay well how do i
normalize that point in a Cartesian
coordinate space with the polar space
right you're always going to have a jump
on me and you're always going to have a
jump on most people in the world and so
one of the things I encourage students
is first of all most people shouldn't
start a company in college you know they
should they should be involved with
great companies and stuff like that we
talk about that later
but one thing I encourage students who
are interested in the startup process to
do is to spend time trying to figure out
where the most breakthrough cutting-edge
work is happening right here on campus
that is technically deep rather than
trying to be the next social networking
app which will get a lot of attention if
it takes off right Evans beagle snapchat
Congrats Kevin Systrom Instagram
Congrats but that's like that's like
saying I want to be like the guy that
got hit by lightning it's very very hard
to deterministically do that okay and
then the next the next advantage is
network effects these in my experience
are more subtle so you know we've had
three investments that I think
demonstrated well Twitter lyft and
twitch.tv
they're you know the the thing that I
would say about network effects is that
if you're gonna build a network affects
a business I think it's important to ask
yourself what is my network what are the
nodes of the network how do they connect
with each other
where the connections strong where are
they not strong is it a global network
is it a hub-and-spoke Network what does
it mean for me to be the network
operator now interestingly network
effect businesses have existed for a
long time they they existed with the
railroads they existed with canals they
existed with like RCA and with records
and TV they existed with Craig McCaw and
the cost Cellular
and all of those people thought of
themselves as not just Lean Startup
innovator you know iterators they they
conceived of what the network was in the
first place and this is a book I highly
recommend it's it's by a guy named Yohai
benkler used to be at Yale I think he
just moved over to Harvard the book is
called the wealth of networks and what I
think is good about it is it takes a
very structured way of thinking - the
approach a building networks and I think
that like just like you wouldn't build a
deep technology business without really
understanding the technology and depth
most people when they build a network
effects business I believe should have
an ongoing hypothesis of their network
at fine-grain detail that evolves in
migration sir time okay so now we're
going to go to product power this is
kind of the mistake I see a lot of
people make I jokingly refer to it as
the product escape process you know
product gets built it escapes out of the
building and into the market and then we
go get customers and and and then we
iterate the customer says oh no no
you're way off and then we say okay well
you know you want you you wanted a left
handed smoke shifter it's to the right
hand and smoke shifter okay I'll make
I'll make make it left-handed but you
know the company just kind of gets off
to a bad start because they have this
wrong idea that it's kind of this
sequential activity where I'm gonna I'm
gonna build a product and then I'm gonna
launch it and try to try to get some
people to use it and then see if I'm
right to me like and so Marc Andreessen
has some great quotes and I'll refer you
to blog that he wrote in a second in a
great market a market with lots of real
potential customers the market pulls
product out of a start-up conversely in
a terrible market you can have the best
product in the world absolutely killer
team it doesn't matter you're going to
fail the number one company killer is a
lack of market Andy Radcliffe has
another way of saying it when a
when a great team meets a lousy market
the market wins when a mediocre team
meets a great market the market often
wins have you ever seen a start-up where
you're like how in the hell could they
have been successful it's because they
met a great market and they just
sometimes your product your market it
just has the magic you can't beat
customers off with a stick they just
want it I've had this happen to me
before where in spite of the fact that
the product just seemed horrible on the
surface it just didn't matter
people people wanted it really bad I'll
give you an example of this where the
market was really good a Chegg we
decided we want to do textbook rentals
is one of our early investments I don't
know does anybody ever use Chegg at
Stanford okay cool so so we're like okay
or textbook rentals gonna work we're
like we don't know we don't even have a
warehouse and so world it's like okay
what do we do so somebody would rent a
textbook from Chegg we'd ship it from
Amazon and they'd call us up and say
what's what's up with this I thought I'm
renting a textbook from jag and you
shipped it from Amazon what's the deal
and we'd say oh it's just a clerical
supply chain error would you please ship
it back to check here's our address but
people put up with it because they just
love the idea of renting a textbook
they're like let me get this straight
textbook cost me a hundred bucks you'll
rent it to me for 35 sign me up
and so they just kept training them no
matter how disorganized we seemed in the
early days so to me product market fit
is more of like a it's more of like a
dance between the product of the market
you know it's like if you ever see two
people doing the tango I look at it like
the product is leading the dance but the
market is tangoing with the product in a
sort of you know I'll try to be g-rated
in my language was sort of an intimate
sort of back and forth between them and
what I find is that if you want to get
the tango right the first thing is to
really identify the market large strong
customer desire and the right time you
want you want to find markets where
people
gravitate to your idea and want it right
now as soon as possible even if it's
half done and then that market pulls the
product you know it so it's interesting
when a market pulls a product this is
what it feels like inside the building
nobody's debating what the features of
the next version ought to be because
they're like oh my god this stuff is
flying off the shelves and our customer
needs us to fix X Y & Z and you're like
okay well let's fix it and so that's
what it feels like when the markets
pulling the product whereas when the
markets not pulling the product the the
conversations in the building are
arguments over why aren't those customer
smart enough to figure out how awesome
our stuff is and you know it's back and
forth and who's that what is my vision
more right than your vision about about
what the product ought to be and then
the last part of it is delighting the
customer in the other direction so you
know the part of the dance where the
customer follows is they're pulling
product and where you lead is you you
assimilate that information on all the
time and then delight the customer so
that so by the way the first thing that
I see we talk about this not doing the
dance is the first mistake I see in
people not achieving product market fit
and conversely the people who do this
well often get to they're faster the
second thing is not clearing the
threshold of delight so a lot of people
think their product is good and that
rational customers ought to like it and
buy it but customers I won't use the
exact words they need to say WTF I
didn't know that that was even possible
are you kidding me
so I'll give you an example with lyft
first launched we had a an associate at
the time it's now Rothenberg ventures
Tommy leap and he was the Stanford treat
for those of you who've been here for a
while
and you know we launched lyft well we
lift launched lyft and we're like I hope
it goes well two weeks after they launch
Tommy comes into the team meeting it
says we're gonna crush it in this deal
and we're like yeah Tommy you know we're
excited about lyft - it's awesome he's
like I've used it ten times in the last
week he's like have you tried it yet
we're like well I'm gonna get around to
it I haven't into San Francisco but you
know I'll check it out he's like dude it
just it rocks you just get out your
phone there's a car on the map you asked
for a car and it picks you up and like
keep in mind this is before Burda sided
to react to lift with uber X it's like
nobody had ever had a service before
we're just some stranger in a car pulls
up when you request the ride it takes
you where you want to go and you know
keep in mind at the time the cabs in San
Francisco were horrible right so you
never get a cab in San Francisco and so
it was one of these experience was where
I remember the first time I tried it it
was obvious to me that this product was
gonna be a huge success there was there
was just no doubt in my mind how many of
you have been in a Tesla with the
autopilot yet okay so let me describe
how it works you know you're driving the
car and then there's this little blue
thing that shows up it looks like a
steering wheel and that means that it
knows enough about the road that it can
self drive if you want it to so you just
double click back the cruise control
stock and it goes boom and then it just
starts driving itself and the first time
that happens you're just like that did
not just happen right you're just like
no way it's like there's just like a
hidden camera here there's like somebody
somebody hiding inside the car right in
the in the in the hood you know there's
this can't be real but what I'm finding
is that more and more in today's world
that's the threshold that you want to
clear so you know we talked earlier
about proprietary power one of the
things that I appreciated about the way
a Yazdi did its product was they didn't
just have topological data analysis
under the hood they actualize that
advantage in the product by making it
look awesome with these fractals and so
the best place is to delight the
customer or in the areas where your
fundamental advantage just sings and if
you stick the landing on that not only
do you delight the customer but it's
really hard for other people to do what
you just did okay
suggested reading and Driessen has a
really good excerpt but good at blog
entry the only thing that matters
it's called it talks all about product
market fit the theory of it why it's
important how to get it how not to you
know I've always liked Steve blanks book
the four steps to the Epiphany and then
the innovators guide to growth has a
great chapter on mastering emergent
strategies and how to systematically
kind of dance that tango with the
customer and turn assumptions about the
product and the customer into facts okay
I think I need to go a little quicker
company power this is for preparing for
rapid scaling there's really two things
we're interested in here one is a
scalable business model and one is
scalable management systems now you
think about it if if you have a product
that people love and that only you can
deliver you'd have to be an idiot not to
be able to make money with that right
because you have something people want
that only you can deliver and so that's
why getting the first foundational parts
are so important you know if you get
proprietary product power nailed you
have a business model you just have to
discover it but it is there always and
then increasing margins and pricing
power are proof that the first two
layers are strong that you know it's
axiomatic that if your pricing power is
going down the first two layers aren't
that strong
either that or you're dumb at pricing
but it's more likely that you've
overestimated how compelling your
product is or how strong your
competitive advantages I think that that
this book business model canvas I think
it's called business model generation
but but the but the the framework is the
business model canvas by Alex
Osterwalder is is is good to look at for
this but a lot of what I find about
business modeling is it's just intuition
you know you just when you get to know
the customer really well what they value
they just it just seems to work the
other thing I found is that customers
often will pay more money when the price
is clear and they will often resist
paying less money when the price is
unclear and so being clear about the
price is very often more important than
having a high price vs. a low price so I
would always tend to be biased towards
having a clear high price that the
customer understands it relates back to
your value scalable management systems I
put these up only just because I call
them out culture do you define it or do
you just kind of let it happen so a lot
of the good companies that I've seen
actually proactively define their
culture and they they emphasize what
that is their first 20 employees and
then it kind of takes a life of its own
why do you want that it's sort of like
when um when ducks fly south for the
winter you don't have to tell the ducks
in the back of the V getting a V they
just know and when a company gets into
blitzscaling mode you don't have time to
tell the hundreds of new employees that
you hire here's how decisions get made
here here's what we value you know
here's how we make trade-offs at the
margin they have to note they have to be
programmed in their the DNA of how they
participate in the company basic
management systems this has to do with
just one on one meetings board meetings
team meetings forecasting frameworks you
know what gets covered in those meetings
what shouldn't get covered in those
meetings just having a sort of a
philosophy of that going in can save a
lot of time and avoid a lot management
debt compensation strategy I'm very
surprised how few companies if I go to
them and say what is the role of cash
stock and bonuses in your company what
is the strategic logic for why you have
each one usually they can't answer that
and being able to answer that
both helps you retain the awesome people
but it also helps you recruit people
with a competitive advantage because
those people rather than just put you in
a line in an auction say oh wow this is
a real company this company has a
philosophy of how they compensate that
must mean that they actually have a
point of view about what makes the
company great and what makes the people
at the company great hot teams we could
get to the Q & A it's one of my favorite
topics but I don't know if I'm gonna
have to I'll do the quick version so
NASA landed on the moon in 1969 and
people are like how the heck did that
happen HP didn't even have a pocket
calculator yet
and they discovered that there were some
teams that were a thousand times more
productive than normal teams one team
had to put an antenna on top of a
mountain and there were no roads up to
the mountain so like what do we do they
say let's ask our boss
we're behind we got to do something they
say oh no no if we ask management
nothing will ever happen so one person
says who has the biggest helicopter in
the entire world and they say I don't
know I don't know so they find out turns
out it's the US Navy they say hey it's
NASA US Navy can you loan us a
helicopter the Navy says screw you NASA
you know I don't you don't get my
helicopters they say ok here's the deal
if we don't get your helicopters we
can't do this antenna and if we don't do
this antenna on top of the mountain
we're not gonna land on the moon in 1969
like JFK said we would and so they say
how many do you need
so flew all the parts the antenna on top
of the mountain assemble the antenna and
the NASA moon landing was a thousand
examples of that and so like when you're
in a start-up you want to have that vibe
of the goal is super important and you
can make it happen and in fact if you
don't make it happen it won't happen
forget performance reviews like great
startups have hot teams cut through the
crap and get through whatever obstacles
are inevitable to come along the way ok
these are three books I recommend annie
groves is awesome high output management
I like Sutton's new book scaling up
excellence and then I also like the
notes from Reid's class Reid Hoffman on
blitzscaling ok category power category
Kings they don't just make something to
sell to people they introduced the world
a new category of product or service
category Kings they replace our point of
view from what we understood yesterday
to what we now believe and ultimately
they change how people in businesses
spend money here are some examples when
I was a kid people didn't pay multiple
dollars for a cup of coffee but
Starbucks convinced me and a whole bunch
of people to rethink our spending hat
as it related to coffee Amazon Web
Services right not just a service a
whole new category
there weren't any digital music players
that would play thousands of songs in
your pocket before the original iPod
fact I would argue that jobs as great
genius in his second act was the
invented three new categories
the digital music player the smartphone
and the tablet this is a example I kind
of like Elvis so Elvis Elvis changed our
point of view from jazz on steroids to
rock and roll you know so Elvis defined
the category of rock and roll
category kings usually capture seventy
to eighty percent of the profit pool and
in a given market these guys I think are
doing some really interesting work play
bigger calm
Christopher Locke head Al Rahma da Dan
have been friends for a long time
they're gonna come out with a book
pretty soon that talks about category
design but I think their website does a
good job of talking about some of these
issues I believe that category design is
going to become an increasingly
prevalent topic in how people think
about building value in their in their
startups okay so I'm gonna go quickly
through this what what is the purpose of
a seed round primarily it's to marry
proprietary product power if using a
seed round I can prove that I've created
something that people love that's
defensible that was a good seed round
and then I just lay early groundwork and
company power and category power the
next round right what I call the
execution around usual it's the a and
the B rounds it's creating the flywheel
for blitzscaling it's hiring those early
executives it's sort of creating sort of
the infrastructure to be able to scale
when product market fit becomes
understood in the company and then the
later stage rounds is about capturing
the profit pool from an emerging
category final thought okay
so you're gonna find you're gonna be
surprised about this you don't have as
much time as you think you all are much
younger than I am but I promise you that
sitting where you're sitting feels like
yesterday and you're in a position of
privilege you know most of you in this
room or Stanford students and so the
thing that I would HIGHLY you to
consider is to only do things that you
think have a chance to be legendary
it takes just as much work to do
something mediocre as to do something
legendary and the mistakes you'll make
if you make them in the next decade or
so will be because you didn't take the
time to consider if the next thing that
you are going to do was truly legendary
don't let yourself be thirty years old
having been at for me do for startups
like that's that's a bad use of your
first decade out of school a good use of
your time regardless of whether you do
start up or not in my opinion is to
always work with the people who excite
you who you think are excellent who will
make you better to engage with the
projects that you think are gonna make a
difference
and just to commit yourself without
exception to doing kick-ass exceptional
work just don't forget that you have
your whole life ahead of you to get the
cumulative benefits of that there will
be temptations there will be chatter and
noise but just turn off the noise and
the height and just stay focused on that
and I think that if you can do that and
and put all your energy and enthusiasm
into those things that have a chance to
be truly legendary that that's how you
get involved in exceptional things that
you're proud of and that you look back
on and you get to enjoy your life twice
because you get to remember or all the
cool things that you did
so anyway I should probably stop and do
Q&A now are there any questions I should
probably take your questions since you
since you sat in the front row I should
probably take your question first do you
care if our listeners tune radioactive
what if I this is like what it felt like
do you how do you assess you know the
viability of a product I think special
regard to technical yeah so let me see
if I can phrase a question right so
you're you're kind of saying okay how
how patient are you with these kind of
technologies that kind of they're
radioactive but maybe they never turn
into the monster right they're just kind
of sitting in a beaker and just they
look radioactive but Geiger counter is
kind of going off but nothing is really
happening it's funny like I like to make
fun of my ability to predict what any of
these startups are gonna do and so my
investment style is to invest in
projects that have super high potential
energy but very ambiguous what I like to
say mechanical energy right I don't know
what it's going to become but I know it
feels very radioactive you know so like
um twitch TV it started out as Justin
not Eve II Justin can walks into a
coffee shop I've never met him before I
was talking to guys from Weebly and
Justin walks in they say hey we think
you're a cool guy and we would like you
to meet Justin he'd like to pitch you he
walks in he's got a baseball cap a
camera and wires going into a backpack I
mean I thought that the security would
stop him somehow right and he says I'm
gonna live cast my life and I'm like I'm
like Justin come on that's too
right that's ridiculous and I'm like but
how do you even do that he says well the
Internet's kind of hostile networking
environment it's really hard to do live
video on the internet so we've invented
a bunch of technologies and I'm there's
me and there's a couple guys from Yale a
couple guys from MIT and we've invented
this way to stream live video over the
hospital networking environment that's
the internet and I was like that's my
kind of deal because I was like okay I
could see live video might be a thing
someday now it ended up morphing into
twitch which you could say arguably is
not really live video but but I've made
more money on those kind of bets you
know Evan Williams right at Twitter he
did this company called audio podcast a
company went out of business he gave me
my money back I said you don't owe me my
money back and he said well you need to
take it because some of the other
investors want back I'm like I'll take
it back only if you let me do your next
thing so he's like I'm working on a side
project I'm gonna call voicemail 2.0 or
Twitter and I'm like what does Twitter
do they says you say what you're doing
and I'm like then what happens and he
says uh 140 characters or less and I'm
like what's the road map there is no
road map what's the revenue model there
is no revenue model well why do you
think this is a company Evan I figured I
did blogger software a million people
wrote blogs I figure if ten million
petite people do microblogs the burden
of proof is on the people who are
negative and I was like that's my kind
of thing and so I believe that in my
stage of the market people try too hard
to predict what's going to happen and
they let all the things that could go
wrong with their prediction cause them
not to invest whereas if I see
exponentially high potential energy I
have a portfolio and a few only only say
a third of them do we have to be right
that they're gonna find the promised
land and so I end to favor the high
potential energy and and just let let
the let the great entrepreneurs do their
work yeah sure
any other questions I'll take you yeah
thank you for being here
structure advantage structural
competitive advantage yeah
so how about when you have a network
effects but it's hyperlocal so it
matters of location like lyft uber or
delivery right yeah so that the what
what some of those companies get wrong
so what lyft got right is they crush San
Francisco before they went to other
towns where they could have gotten
themselves in trouble would have been to
say well we got the first mover
advantage let's go into five cities
right away and spread out and spread
their efforts to thin and so like it
kind of goes back to sort of network
theory we we knew that lift if it worked
was gonna be sort of like almost like a
hub-and-spoke network where you prove
the network effect in one town and then
based on the success metrics of that
proof you raise money to go into other
towns I think the other thing that lyft
got right is they understood that they
were gonna have to raise a lot of money
to make to build this kind of network
and so if you're gonna if you're gonna
have look networks that start local and
then spread you have to convince
yourself in my opinion that you have the
team and the idea and the credibility to
raise a whole lot of money if you
succeed locally fast I think you also
have to succeed locally fast right like
if you're kind of busting your pick
against succeeding locally you just kind
of get trapped there and never so you
know you want you want the network
locally to hyper accelerate and then you
need to be it be the kind of team that
can walk in to andreessen horowitz like
the lyft guys didn't say I want sixty
million dollars and to spread spread
this idea but but there's a there's a
very important timing and sequence to
doing that yeah and and by the way it's
a very good point there are all kinds of
companies that are raising money for
food delivery Network effects kind of
stuff and I don't understand how they
raised like a lot of these companies I
don't know how they ever make money but
I am thankful that they'll deliver my
food to me you know thanks and Hill Road
yeah yes given here ten out of ten
thousand companies 297
prophets give or take so that's one in a
thousand that's a terrifying thought to
any investor how do you convince
rational people to put up their money
through this kind of risk okay so the
question is let me get this straight
you invest in an asset class where ten
out of ten thousand make 97% of the
money that sounds super risky how like
what what person would ever give you
money to go invest in that approach to
investing okay what what we find is that
venture capital is kind of like a
lottery game where the same people seem
to keep getting the winning tickets and
so the way you convince someone to
invest in a venture fund is you convince
them that you have some proprietary
insight or attack vector or unfair
advantage into accessing those top ten
companies I think that if you do not
have that by the way your venture
capital fund doesn't have a business
right so like I would say conversely if
you don't have an unfair advantage to
getting those winning lottery tickets
and this is by the way why so many
venture firms lose money almost almost
every single venture firm loses money
and then a small fraction that keep
getting the winning lottery tickets make
crazy good buddy and so you know the key
is just like when your startup the key
is as a fund to convince the investor
that you're a hyper exceptional venture
fund and in the end I think you either
have to have a great strategy or you
just have to have the result and say
it's an existence proof yes Tina so
you've told us these great stories about
these companies that we all know about
what about the things you're investing
in now that you're most excited about oh
gosh
let's see what should we talk about
because some of them may not want us to
talk about it yet they're there's a
company that we invested in in 2014
called lob that is doing sort of like AP
is for physical print so they're kind of
in the genre of like stripe and Twilio
and they've gotten off to very fast
starting there there they're doing very
well there's a company that's super
early that I'm excited about called
dispatcher that was started by a
actually a computer science student here
at Stanford that is a close some very
large contracts that are unusually large
for how for how young they are so I
think that they they're doing a really
good job you know an has an investment
and a company that I think is showing a
lot of signs of being interesting called
Viraj sale which is you know moving
pretty quickly and what else are some of
the recent ones that you'd say reading
that we can talk about the greatest is I
think as a has a chance of being really
good and there's a few that aren't quite
as famous yet that we feel like we've
been working with for a long time that I
think are good you know refinery29 you
know Dan Greenberg dropped us Stanford's
start share through they're doing really
well yeah so and then and then there's a
few I wish I could talk about but I just
don't want to put put the guys on the
spot yet not in front of your huge
podcasting audience yeah yes sir so it
seems like there's a lot of companies
that are ruling in category now that
weren't actually the original animator
in that field so Facebook obviously came
out to friends too but was able to sort
of take that freshmen advantage away
from them so do you feel like that it's
more important to be on the cutting edge
of the technology or to identify you
know when it and then somehow overtake
that it in its you know the way I sort
of look at it is first of all there's
there's a whole lot of randomness in
startups right so a lot of this stuff is
just super hard to predict and you could
after the fact you can tell all kinds of
stories about why the facts fit what
happened I sort of look at like the
value stack is almost like a pre-flight
check you know something like okay
startups to play and I'm about to take
off on the runway and do I want to do
that because like once once I'm in the
air you know I'm going and so like I
wouldn't necessarily say that like
proprietary power or without product
power I would never do
investment or that I've never seen a
company succeed or that I've never seen
a company first-mover or B not the
category keen or whatnot it's more I
like to encourage entrepreneurs to sort
of before they will that sucker into
existence you know to kind of ask the
diagnostic questions that that kind of
give them a sense for do I want to
really commit my life to this the thing
I think that Zuckerberg just got some
things incredibly right at Facebook you
know not only the product and the team
but um he was like a sponge in terms of
asking people questions you know he's
always always learning more always
wanting to learn as much as he could and
I just think he's it was just incredibly
gifted entrepreneurs the right place the
right time and you know you could argue
some of the other people made mistakes
you could argue they were too early and
it's like all markets their time comes
and sometimes being too early is just as
wrong as being too late you know you
just timings a big deal and so you know
he was at the right place at the right
time in fact he was at a time when
people were starting to not like social
networks they're like well Friendster
didn't work tribe didn't work this is
one for colleges big whoop and you know
he benefited from the fact that not that
many people cared anymore about social
networking he just quietly went about
his business and hired awesome technical
people made it happen with incredibly
educational and inspiring
you